I have the sweetest husband in the
entire world it's been nearly one month
since Stephen twitch boss died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound now a
source tells E.T how his wife Allison
holker is keeping his memory alive for
their children we're just very proud we
definitely have some hams in the bunch
right like you know and and what degree
of entertainment that's gonna be all of
them are different and all of them have
no problem commanding a room even our
little one-year-old Allison and twitch
have two children together six-year-old
son Maddox and three-year-old daughter
ziya twitch is also dad to Allison's 14
year old daughter Wesley from a previous
relationship we love the Full House and
also just like family man like honestly
they're my favorite they're my favorite
people you know what I mean E.T Source
says while it's been a very difficult
time Allison has always been a strong
person quote she is trying to keep her
composure and not break down in front of
her kids through this process for their
sake
[Music]
our source adds that the mom of three is
prioritizing their mental well-being
especially her oldest daughter since she
understands what's going on quote
Allison is making sure that all the kids
know how much their daddy loves them
that he is still with them and his
spirit is still flourishing that this
has nothing to do with them and that
they can do things to help keep his
Spirit Alive
I'm still in a lot of shock
um my daughter is really close with
Wesley his daughter and our kids went to
school together and he and I went to
college together and um
yeah it's a lot so news of twitch's
death rocked Hollywood many of his
friends mourned his loss while speaking
with E.T he's such a talent and such an
amazing warm wonderful heart and uh yeah
he will be he will be greatly missed
according to our source Allison's been
receiving so much support and an
outpouring of Love since her husband's
sudden death specifically from her
family his family and the Dancing with
the Stars Community quote everyone has
really come together to congregate
around her and her kids
we've always crossed Paths of twitch and
he is was the nicest guy ever it's a
really sad unfortunate I'm hoping that
it can be used as a reminder to people
that
um you never know life is precious and
uh and you never know he has had
definitely a profound impact on me I
just thought he was an angel Stephen
twitch was such a significant part of
the dance Community but then he had this
amazing ability to go way beyond that
and he just lit up every room and he was
so positive I think anyone who's ever
met twitch will say that he is the
nicest most caring most
you know present person and and really
wants to make everyone feel better it's
so hard to believe and so thoughts and
prayers to Allison and the kids and and
everyone
[Music]